the year was 1946 radio was king and the
Adventures of Superman ruled the
airwaves but with fascism vanquished the
Man of Steel set his sights on a
different foe this is the story of how
Superman busted the ku klux klan because
unless we stop this fiery cross klan now
they'll get you no matter where you go
the story starts with Stetson Kennedy a
journalist who infiltrated the Klan for
the anti-defamation league he wanted to
melt the cultural glue that held the
Klan together thanks Rick no problem
that's Rick Bowers Bo W at this book
Superman versus the Ku Klux Klan
boy the Stetson Kennedy have to do with
Superman remember the last Son of
Krypton needed a new enemy the producers
of the radio show on a very bold gambit
decided Superman would take on real life
hate groups the creators of The
Adventures of Superman used Kennedy's
research to produce a 16 part series
called the clan of the fiery cross where
a great secret society played to purify
America
- Superman producers went to the
anti-defamation league and said
authenticate our script provide us more
information was a way to get the message
out that no one else could get out just
by telling horror stories I'm the Grand
scorpion of the clan of the fiery cross
I am a rat kill me it exposed the Klan
as hate mongers but it also exposed the
Klan as a money-driven organization I'm
running a business rigs and so are you
we deal in one of the oldest and most
profitable commodities on earth hate it
was a breakthrough in American
broadcasting not only had they done this
great public service but they elevated
themselves to the number one radio show
for kids on air while their cowardly
gangsters who operate at night hidden
behind sheets and hoods their minds are
diseased with hate don't want to say
from I guess you could say that the
white road stood no chance against the
Man of Steel
you